so when you start to think about uh this
idea of uh securing digital assets you
said that basically that's the whole
point of cryptos this idea of
self-sovereignty what are some of the
things that people should be looking at
when they're evaluating how they are
going to secure their assets there's in
my mind a couple of different things
they can do right that you have uh
wallets that are attached to regulated
exchanges you have software wallets you
have hardware wallets you have cold
storage you have multi-sig
all these different ways to secure these
digital assets how do you walk people
through kind of the evaluation process
for what's the right thing for them and
what they're trying to accomplish
i mean the main question is is always
like where are the private keys um and
so if you trust a third party with your
private keys the question becomes
okay what's the actual security they
have and what's the what are the rules
of governance
but sometimes the keys are secure like
you know there are in a
you know you trust your keys to
a certain company
the keys will be eventually secure
because they're either in the nano s or
their which is often the case or in an
hsm hardware security module so secure
servers where you can put private keys
the question is not so much the security
of the private keys is more the question
of the governance like who has access to
the keys etc and so you've seen in the
horror stories that the market
has had in the past
it's usually the question of
who has access to those keys
and sometimes you see you know people
disappearing and up suddenly no one has
access to to the funds anymore and so
it's fundamentally a governance issue
and so it's very hard for uh consumers
to to figure that out so so usually
you know trust the the big guys that
have the funds the funds to pay you back
in case they're being hacked you know
this is what binance
does really well with their safety funds
or
when you have a company like coinbase
that is now sort of regulated and and
listed you know
eventually they pay you they'll pay you
money back but there is always a risk
and you know actually if you if you look
at the deal that you have with your bank
now i'm talking about the fiat system if
your bank goes bankrupt actually you
know uh they don't owe you much like if
you have million dollars in your bank
account and you know they go bankrupt
they don't have actually to pay back
and so when you when you work with a
custodian or if you trust a custodian
with your money like it obeys the same
rules there is no guarantee that you
ever see your money if something
happened
and in the case of crypto you know there
is a strong case that
these
um exchanges or you know consumption
could be hacked and so really the
question becomes what is the security
layer that run on if you look at kraken
for example and what jc says and what
practicum says publicly they say don't
leave your funds on the exchange and you
know retrieve your funds and you know
keep them securely with you on a
self-custody wallet okay and then the
question becomes okay but now if i'm
self-considering my funds what should i
do so pro tip of the day
never leave your funds on a software
wallet on your phone or on your computer
these are not secure enough
we have actually videos you can look on
our website where we extract the private
keys of software wallet in less than 30
seconds
it's almost all
software wallets
and it's not really their fault it's
just the fact that software wouldn't
rely on computers or phones that have
not been designed for for security and
so you can attack the phone or the
computer at the operating system level
and sort of drain everything that sits
on top of it
so software has not been designed to
secure uh crypto private keys so really
if you're self considering your keys
hardware is your only bet today it's not
just your best bet it's your only bet so
if you have your coins in a metamask for
example please do pair it with a
hardware wallet we believe ledger is the
best hardware right now in the market
but there are others
and uh and the private keys need to be
in in hardware so if you're self
considering the keys it has to be in
secure hardware uh at some point
so when you start to think about that
hardware wallet itself you've talked a
little bit about the best practices for
uh securing things how should people
evaluate hardware um in terms of what
they should use what they should i
always tell folks you know a simple
thing is don't buy any hardware device
from a third party go and buy it
directly from the uh the creator whether
it's ledger or somebody else but when
you all think about uh building these
products how do you expect
uh the end user to actually evaluate the
hardware there's certain features that
are more important than others or what's
that evaluation process look like
you know first of all i think that if
you're going to handle your own security
you know you need to to spend the time
and you know to educate yourself i think
you know trying to
uh
trying to fast-track yourself into this
world is is a bad idea so there is a lot
of education educational content
everywhere on sort of everything ledger
has a lot of educational content in the
ledger academy and we spend a lot of
time and money just to to build this
content so people know what they're
doing and so
know that
when you go to self-custody it's a bit
like in the matrix you're taking the red
pill i think so you're exiting from the
matrix
and so suddenly you need to
sort of forget everything you think you
know and you know learn this new world
and
you know
taking care of your own security and
taking care of like digital assets is
actually something very new so you
should be very mindful of what you're
doing next you know in web 2 you
download an app and you say yes yes yes
we've all done this it's like you say
yes to everything you don't read the
fine prints and then you move on
i think you shouldn't be careless with
web3 and with crypto in general like you
should really pay attention to to what
you do because sometimes you know
mistakes
um
nobody's going to fix that mistake for
you right because suddenly you're in
charge of your of your own funds and
then when it comes to choosing a
hardware wallet i mean there are a bunch
of
youtubers there are a bunch of reviews
so again it's back back to uh to the
education process
um and um
and you know like hardware wallets are
battle tested every day so you can read
reviews you can you can read about you
know
what's what's safer uh usually
ledger rates pretty highly so so
basically the answer is get a letter uh
anthony like
that's the best answer i can give you
right now that
of course that's what you think right
um let's just exactly it's actually
documented i mean ledger is the safest
out there
we sold five million devices uh versus
the rest of the market that i've sold
you know around one point something
uh and and also
now seriously the good way of
of thinking about a hardware what it is
you know it's two things it's
security but also ease of use so
security you know there you can document
yourself you know let your ranks pretty
high when it comes to security actually
it ranks the highest
when it comes to ease of use then it
becomes the software okay what is the
software that comes with the the
hardware that is provided with the
hardware with it so at ledger we have
ledger live ledger live is becoming a
really great value proposition in itself
like as a as a as a wallet in itself i
mean it's great and so you need to you
need to look at that you need to look at
all the software and make your decision
and then you need to look at also
compatibility so
you know your your hardware can link to
uh let your life sure but okay what can
what can you what can you link to as
well so typically
your ledger wallet is compatible with
your coinbase wallet it's compatible
with a bunch of wallets that are that
are out there so i think this is the
three things i will check you know
security of the wallet the software that
comes with the wallet
uh and then the competitive
compatibility of your hardware with
other software services and i think on
these three things
ledger ranks number one right now which
is why i say get a ledger hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time